[Music]
hello and welcome to ultimate moves the
sink field cup might be over but we've
got an exciting event today featuring
all of those elite players definitely
the true competition has is about to
start i think as we have the classic
matchup of randy singfield against rex
singfield here
in the st louis chess club
and maurice ashley is with tony rich the
executive director here at the club to
explain it all
well what happens when you take ten of
the best players in the world tossed in
a former world champion by the name of
gary kasparov of yasser ciron one of the
great legends of the game and have them
play against two uh well modest players
will call it racing field and randy
singh field as they continue their
rivalry in blitz
tag team chess there's going to be chaos
here today oh that old tournament the
singfill cup that's long gone well tony
rich is here to explain to us exactly
what the format is tony exactly how have
you designed this so that there's
maximum chaos oh absolutely i made sure
to invite rexingfield so that he would
make sure that everything kind of blows
up at the board
the players will rotate out every five
moves kind of like tag team rex and
randy will start sitting at the board
playing once they make their five moves
they'll rotate out next up for rex will
be gary kasparov next up for randy will
be wesley so and they'll keep rotating
through every five moves like that if
the game goes long enough we'll rotate
back in rex and randy and i'm sure
they'll find a way to blow up the
position again
now officially what are the rules is it
fide rules we saw rex have a little
hiccup in the first year that's right if
you recall i had to forfeit rex and
former world champion gary kasparov
which was not necessarily the most
exciting time but i've been told
to keep the rules strict so uh touch
move illegal move loses
pawn promotion done improperly like last
year we'll lose also so we will follow
strict rules on this we have our chief
arbiter tracy vibbert here to make sure
that all the players follow the rules
well it's supposed to be a good time but
these players are serious you saw when
rex made that illegal move they jumped
all over him they just want to win so we
should have a lot of fun oh and by the
way trash talking is allowed
trash talking is a lot i think trash
talking is encouraged that some of these
players well they're going to try to
psych out their opponents
and here's one of our team captains
randy singfield you recognize the name
grand master randy singh grandmaster wow
promotion
he is the founder of spectrum studios
which puts together this production
every year absolutely and i've seen
randy play i know that he's been
practicing for the event
he's feeling the pressure though oh of
course i mean i actually find it
admirable that these guys do this every
year i mean
i know if i was on a team with any of
these players i'd be pretty terrified
myself of blundering like thundering
something yeah some of the best chess
players in the world but they understand
that they gotta pick it up they'll start
with the first five moves around the n
rec so i think they'll be able to
survive that one easily but the next
round when they come back that's the
true test that's right and a lot of the
strategy is about setting them up well
for that five moves first of all not
getting into time pressure that's huge
you want to make sure that the sync
fields when they come back in have a
couple minutes right and it's a much
faster time control than we had last
year so they have to be very careful
we're playing in the same format that we
had in the blitz terminal for the us
championship five minutes with three
second delay that's right and we've got
maurice ashley with more info on what
we're about to see
well we actually have a bit of a
challenge already fabiano caruana is
missing from the building they're trying
to track him down now
without a player obviously there'll be
nobody to make moves so they're trying
to track him down to get him as quickly
as possible into the playing hall so
that we can continue we'll see and let
you know what exactly happens
wow fabiano um of course
uh
the sinkfield champion from two years
ago but it's always the local guy that's
laid right it's always the local guy
that's late i mean yes he's staying at
the chase park plus out of the hotel
across the street basically
so we'll get him in here bobby
go check yourself um we've got
team rex which is going to be
rexingfield starting the play followed
by gary casavara legend of the game
fabiano carolina he current nakamura
then we've got anishiri ding loren and
peter spindler so we're actually going
to get them to see them all play moves
today
it's going to be really exciting
randy's team
includes our champion wesley so
vishy anna and vessel and topalov next
team bashir lagrave lavon aroni and
beyonce heroine and i'm hearing cheers
all throughout the club because that's
an old-school pick of mr randy singfield
and kind of still is a surfer dude no
definitely a surfer that's right he goes
to costa rica every year
yeah but now that he
goes to costa rica goes back to malibu
and that's where he grew up and really
um he caught the surfing bug
well how he tracked down fabiano that
seems to be the main challenge right now
main question indeed um and we are going
to be using the hashtag ultimate moves
for this competition
so goodbye singfield cop hello ultimate
moves i think this is the most fun event
i i've really ever seen yeah there's two
amateurs just throwing in a wrench
great chess players that just not only
love competition but they're very joking
they like playing this kind of
for fun chess it's my favorite format
actually i love like there's the
introduction introduction i mean i play
poker as also
adding that randomness is really fun but
at the same time you see a real chess
game and fabiano carolina
i'm sure he's feeling um
excited about his team i mean he comes
late and he finds out that his uh
partner is gary caspara that can't be
the worst feeling in the world
so we have the two main players that
everybody cares about what happens today
they have no pressure on them actually
they have all the pressure on them in
the world randy singh field the son of
rexingfield randy the score is 1-1
between you and your dad how are you
feeling about this year the grudge match
i feel great look at my team look at
this we're organized we're calm
we're happy look at these guys they're
late they're disorganized i don't know
what's going on over here he's in
trouble he's in trouble
rex is it important that you win today
of course it's important and i'll call
randy look at his team
look at his team we're going to crush
him look at this
look this is your one last chance you
guys can resign right now
the trash talking has begun folks so
we're going to get the rules going the
players will start and we'll get much
more trash talking coming as the games
begin
the interesting thing is both players
actually got their dream teams i was
talking to randy before the event and
this is exactly the team he wanted
that's great that's right everybody wins
i mean although with these players you
can't really lose can you and we've got
the game going game number one here blue
normal spanish roy lopez here
gary with baited breath hoping that rex
plays bishop anymore
definitely influenced by
well is that fine
yes
the winner of the single couple wesley
so
wesley famously said that gary actually
was somebody he studied before the
singfield cup he's a big fan and he was
quite honored to be next to gary
kasparov at the closing ceremonies
wow this already looks a little bit
dangerous for black i think
this early b5 move known to be a little
bit of a mistake
yeah but not that easy
he's an attacking genius it looks like
the time control is actually a delay as
opposed to a three second increment so
it's definitely a delay
i think wes is confused about getting up
or down
was this already standing up
anticipating gary's next move
gary relishing the moment
and he has castle
and 96
on the board in albuquerque
[Music]
and fabiano caruana
past winner
is fabiano caruana but vishyanan coming
in second place tied for second in the
event
part of already shaking his head about
what's happened so far
gary what's your opinion of wise games
[Applause]
and everybody's already deathly silent
i think we're
he's cheering in this moment
what are your thoughts yesterday about
what's happening so far it's excellent
most excellent we've got
exactly the strategy that we prepared
for we had it on our computer this
morning
so paula felt like a mistake was made g5
a stronger move for black but it didn't
happen
and now nakamura going on the assault
lavon what are your chances in this
position i think we're winning
as black yes i like this is positional
masterpiece yeah
he knows these positions he studied them
when he was little
very confident very good
peter this is your first time here to
even experience the seafood cup now
you're in this crate craziness what's
your thoughts about it well i'm enjoying
it because i don't have to play this
vision with white so
that's awesome
i might not actually get the chance so
you're saying it's that bad that you
think white's already lost
we
you showed up late did you not want to
come chase today was there some trash
talking involved you were trying to
avoid
uh yeah
i was a bit late um that's probably the
reason that we have this position
i feel like i caused some i have some
concentration amongst the right here all
right here comes out
curious
specialist by the way these gentlemen
were up late last night playing bug
house
late late into the night [ __ ] three
o'clock in the morning when i left they
were still playing so that was their
preparation for today yeah i actually am
trying to put pieces on the board yeah
give me something
[Applause]
do you surprise in your world are you
surprising me
i thought i'm not gonna get to play any
moves but uh
yeah you are in the game you should be
having attack right now
randy
is famous for his comebacks
all right gary i'm going to ask you
again what do you think about wise
position it's a little bit better than
before but
i'm not by you
i don't know
all right gary hasn't gotten into his
full trash talking mode just yet
i think they did
it looks like the white side is feeling
quite good about themselves suddenly
about the potential
you are not the right person to deliver
to find the forced win
[Music]
okay but we will
easy winning two moves come on yes
it's not you'll tell it you know in the
post more
all right there's a lot of bluffing
going on right now i think it's poker
i was not sure
all right analysis going on and black is
up in exchange
uh for the morning okay
we can yeah
[Music]
and that's it the fifth move played by
anish gary and now it's dingler in
coming down into the seat
do they do do they do any trash talking
in china do you're allowed to talk
during games
very complicated
thing doesn't want to say anything they
have some kind of decorum that we don't
have in the united
a piece down now i have
extra material so
nice
this is my last move and now i'm out
and the time is still plenty of time on
the clock they both have over two
minutes both sides
in such a position almost so good
is a
you've been quiet this whole time what's
your opinion of what's been going on
we're winning of course
ever confident in nakamura
and finally the time is starting to take
down and equalize just a little bit two
minutes and one second for white two
minutes and only 16 seconds and ticking
down they had about a minute edge
earlier but it's going to start getting
a bit closer as it gets tense and f4 has
been played we have to do this
we have to create space for our pieces i
think bing is considering to offer
what was that
[Laughter]
you can step in front of me
the chinese number one and his talk is
ticks for over 30 seconds on this one
pawn sacrifice
and he's thinking about it still costing
costing them on the clock
and he declined to capture the pawn
backing up
the danger double me and gary
hey
during a game whatsoever
but uh it's clock ticking and it's now
yeah there's still almost any problem
applause for brazilians
[Applause]
and it's their turn there's only one
minute 11 seconds for white to speed up
as they made their two moves in a row
and rex is at rex stingfield and
randy will come in to play a cleanup at
the end of this we'll see how it goes as
the time starts to tip down quickly
material
and that's it and now rex singfield
coming to the board he will have to play
the next five moves
and the yasser has played and here comes
randy five moves now from these plays
can they maintain the tension that the
grand master's playing a g3 on the board
58 seconds left on the clock to 130 for
black
and the players are feeling the tension
right now
don't let him go
[Applause]
not looking happy about the situation
but it's all about the clock now can the
players play good moves
with the clock ticking down
still
almost a minute plus
this last move for rex stingfield and
he's traded rooks he's trading up to
gigas barb happily coming to the board
intimidating brandy after knight takes
and now takes on a5 a pass pawn for
white
and
top top gm's now at the board very
difficult position
to have to deal with gary already uh
kissing this one goodbye
but only 48 seconds on the clock for
white i'm pretty sure they think they
can handle the situation fabi what do
you think about this absolutely over i
think rex did an amazing job
won a pawn and and now there's two
connect two past pawns just
rex they're giving you all the credit
for this how do you feel hearing this
from the gm's crediting your move well i
feel bad for black black should resign
save himself some honor and dignity you
know what i'm saying
well i don't see a problem
exactly
oh yeah
[Music]
having to defend this with the black as
fabiano caron advances his upon down the
board
and it looks like black feels confident
about their chances again
[Music]
it
is
it is really easy
ticking down he's only 11 seconds left
he's gotta make a move at some point
taking down
wow and he's advanced with the move c5
white with 30 seconds plus the knight
had to drop back
no respect
king marching in and now d4 attacking
the bishop six seconds
bishop to a5
only three seconds two one and the time
is over
i really like the way rex play those
five moves definitely out playing randy
yeah it was actually a pretty well
played game i think actually the teams
made a bit of a tactical error in
leaving randy and rex so little time
going into their 40 40 what was it 45th
moves
absolutely we got well the winner of the
first game rexing filled with maurice
we're with rexingfield after a winning
game one rex that was a well-played game
no mistakes on
the part of the amateurs at least and
you really provided the impetus at the
end winning a pawn yeah you know i
thought was most interesting was the
beginning we started with a very
traditional willy lopez and gary comes
in there and he complicates that thing
so much with his next five moves a
version of the rui that frankly i'm not
totally familiar with i began to wonder
oh boy where's this going and i'm going
to have to clean this up at the end how
does it feel you're sitting there these
are the legends of our time the greatest
players in the world and you know you're
going to have to sit down at some point
and make moves that compliment theirs
i have to make moves that i hope will
not cause them to get sick and die or
throw up you know that's all i have to
do
avoid a disaster well the result is a
win for you against your son you're up
one you're feeling confident about the
rest of the competition i think so but
it's going to be tough you notice randy
has improved a lot in the last year he's
no pushover at all all right well we'll
see what happens game two coming up in
just a few minutes
let's take a look at the standings and
rex making fun of gary castrov you gotta
love it um team rex oh my gosh that's a
great photo
with this name those carl knows that and
team randy in another surfing pose i
think these uh these images um eric
mosel and the rest of the spectrum
studios team clearly having some fun
today but john let's talk about the
first game i think the clear mistake
there was by yasser sarah one who when
you think about it has a lot of pressure
and he needs to give randy a good
position to play in but he plays a
speculative sacrifice with a5 right at
the end of the day was what cost in the
game yeah because randy didn't realize
that without the rooks on the board
that's going to be devastating i also
think that they didn't leave them with
enough time i think they really want to
get them into that situation with about
two minutes so that each player can have
about 30 seconds to sink into the
position i completely agree with you jen
mistakes from team randy very well
exploited by team rex that's right and
the next round how are they going to
adjust their strategy it's going to be
quite interesting to say
yeah absolutely and i think there's a
lot of lessons to be learned and it's i
really love the clash of styles because
at some point you saw white going very
aggressively for the offensive he was
pushing pawns attacking on the queen
side and then dingley reign came in and
he traded off into a slightly better end
game i love how
we had like four crazy attackers like
kasparov came in and fabiano played a
couple of moves then anish started
throwing his pieces forward and dingler
and just calmed down the game so much
absolutely you want to show the opening
with b5 because that was a slightly um
uncommon move
in the roy right so usually b5 became
played this early absolutely randy
played the move b5 here which is
actually considered to be slightly
dubious after bishop b3 knight f6 it's
this move d4 that's supposed to catch uh
black a little bit off guard as after
pawn takes d4 e5 now this bishop on this
diagonal
is quite powerful the knight has to go
to e4 and after bishop d5 white's
considered to have a little bit of an
edge
and back to maurice we are getting game
two started yes
well with a one o result in the books
for rexing fields we know that randy's
gonna have to make a big comeback a push
in game two randy what are your thoughts
about the result at the moment
he defended very well you know he played
well i just have to play better
after all he is the godfather of chess
so this time the god son is going to
show him how it's done
right
what you talking about man
all right we're going to start the game
game two about to go underway
[Music]
very recently
keep playing
randy came out with a power opening and
has put it to black immediately to have
to defend this position
certainly some weak dark squares in
black's formation and kasparov not too
thrilled and look at wesley soh
on the assault already
so casper putting pressure
all right black realizes that there's
some danger here and kasparov's studying
the position because he knows there's a
big attack that's coming at him and he
has to get his pieces out while white
has tremendous amount of space this kind
of position kasparov is famous for
himself and a queen side almost
illegally executed with two hands by
wesley so but he did it with one hand
make sure
he did that the right way and now
with his last move
into the chair
make five moves
yeah i think the game is practical
gary's 94 was too optimistic
oh
[Applause]
how are you feeling about this aneesh
you're a great defender it's a stonewall
structure nothing's going on
let's find the bishop.7 is going to be a
beast the king oh wow long castle we are
doing perfect
you're hitting the move
no no you cannot play longer
[Music]
it's
[Music]
looks very dangerous given where black's
king is and now the knight
running back
now you will see what's happening
which number was that
that's four one more move for anan now
he wants to definitely put his signature
on this position before he's got to get
up and he's playing knight
[Applause]
as a vicious attacking player vasily
topolov
pranced into the chair thrilled to have
this kind of position with the white
pieces and now rook a3 and look at that
left by the rook devastating attacking
position as nakamura comes down to
defend
i won't have to play move in this game
i'm supposed to play in four moves but i
think it will be over
very confident maxine vashila grav and
now he's even pointing out threats his
basilian toppola
i think you should keep your hand off
the table at least but h6 is coming
[Music]
nakamura one of the best blitz players
on the planet now trying to mix things
up you know what they say never trust
your opponent
and not accepting any sacrifices vassily
toppolov just deciding to point his king
his bishop back at the king and ikaro
still ignoring the queen side completely
completely as he continues his assault
on the position nakamura defending with
amazing complications
and now a trade on c6 with check and a
bishop positional chest yet again into
e5 topalov now getting up
and maximum despite his predictions have
had to sit down and make a couple of
moves and now
and now banging down his capture was
aneesh geary grabbing that pawn
it looks as though white is not as
confident as they used to be fabi they
always ruin their position in time for
maxima
right when he gets on the chair this
position is just ruined
i mean i just feel bad for the guy
now suddenly maxime has to make moves
from what looked like a gorgeous
position for white now it's black's turn
in the defense on top of all his
problems he's also a frenchman
[Applause]
sacrifice
accepted
but here comes
maxine vashila grav looking for a big
attack
and he's smiling now
[Applause]
the way he pressed that down with
confidence in europe did geary and now
mexican by the grove has to leave one
more move no no more moves he has to
leave it and lavon aronian is next
[Music]
confidence
will they be able to stave off the white
onslaught and levon aronian deep and
thought trying to figure out exactly
what to do
i will just pass
not only i could also retreat but
yes and now the offer of a queen trade
to beat back white's attack totally
rejected immediately and now rook up to
d6 playing defense
i thought the attack was going to break
through but ding has actually played
really well unfortunately
and
it's trouble for us
all right down the piece is white but
with tremendous compensation as he's
preparing all his forces to mass against
the white the black king
and dingler in bringing his rook in is
one more move for lavon
one more move before the next team comes
up
okay do it for me
[Music]
time not really a factor although white
is ahead by a minute on the clock and
lavon is thinking deeply about what he
should do now he wants to make a real
move to put pressure on black but black
seems to be defending for the moment
now trading
ropes fabiano did not seem happy with
that last year maybe it's a good move
but i wanted to play it would be fine
and now peter fiddler joining yasser in
the chair certainly a defensive position
again
down a piece
uh 217 on the clock for white 138 for
black black has to
figure out how to get going here
as long as vaseline doesn't come and
ruin the game
no i just have to you know make the
things that are easy to make them more
complicated
most interesting
players
for quite some time in this position and
their clock is now down under a minute
as he played c6 and allowed a rook into
b6
brought his queen back to defend am i so
serious yeah
what was the point
well it's been done and now
it's time for yasser he's two minutes on
his clock plenty of time down a piece is
white but with tremendous compensation
elbow grease that one
huge position for white except he's down
a piece for the moment but black has
very few moves to make and black is
currently at 57 seconds now he's brought
his queen to d6 the
black
players with black don't feel too happy
rex's team seems uh disgruntled at the
last sequence but yasser still has to
find the win
genius yes yes sir yeah
yeah sir yes sir yes sir yeah
one more
one more move by yeah one spidler
finally bringing his knight back
and then randy and rex will be uh
will they be able to finish it off there
goes a pawn critical pawn as yasser now
leaves and queen e7 and now it's randy
and rex
with
rex having with black 46 seconds randy
has a full 134 on his clock
will they be able to continue the game
in proper style still a complicated
position white having certainly a lot of
compensation for the material and he's
taking a pawn off the board
and now
it's actually
two pawns
three make that yeah two puns for the
piece but still so much advantage for
the white forces but no panic he says
rex with only 34 seconds he's captured
on a6
and the
king can randy finish it off
continue the attack we've got one minute
and 20 seconds
the king moving over and yet another one
how many more one more
one more move to go
yes
[Music]
and the tension is building as randy is
now under a minute as white on the clock
joining black although black has only 33
seconds left
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
oh i needed this win man i'm confident
cool look at these guys look at this
team behind me are you kidding me this
is amazing we are here to vote
good luck today wendy played better
moves than
[Applause]
well we'll throw it vesseling down to
you in the studio game three we'll start
in a few minutes wow that was just an
incredible game i was in pins and
needles let's take a look at the end
where maxine vasyar lagrave said that
randy played better than vessel and well
i think vesseling was the true villain
at the beginning because he blew all of
white's advantage but it was this
position where's villar with the black
pieces he should have just taken the
pawn on d4 attacking the knight on c5
the queen cannot come to b4 because of
the trade that would have pretty much
ended the game instead he had played
this pretty horrible move c6 rook b6
queen c7 and suddenly you can see white
starts getting a lot of pressure but the
true finish was randy stingfield
scintillating attack he played the move
knight takes a6 bishop takes which is a
big mistake because now the bishop one
of the bigger defenders of the king was
removed and suddenly with an exposed
king randy came up with a couple of
precise checks and team
rex was forced to resign since the move
rook c6 is coming next and that is the
end of the queen wipes up too much
material there is no way they would have
survived and they were down on the clock
significantly one hero of that game i
got to point out though nakamura i mean
he like really i feel like he kind of
brought the game back into black's favor
at some point actually nakamura blunder
very really where in uh let's see
because he was playing against vaseline
right
no i think he was after vesseling right
but no knight b5 right in this position
i think both sides missed uh a really
nice tactic i think it was after age six
yeah but that's hard to see okay so
you're saying you were saying knight
takes g6 but then we can play like queen
then we can play queen eight right no
but the tactic they missed i thought was
completely brilliant if they played
knight takes d5 this attacks the queen
you cannot take with this knight because
of the pin and if you take with this
pawn knight takes c6 is check and you
have discovery on the queen i think
knight takes d5 is something vesseling
would normally see in a blitz game and
they would have just that's game that's
game over yeah but this is a little
different because there's a lot of
pressure to play it almost like a bullet
game because you really want to leave
rex and randy with more time on the [ __ ]
well that still doesn't justify i think
moving backwards so often and suddenly
when giri put that queen on h4 it was
clear black had taken over but at the
end of the day the defense was just not
enough yeah somebody drama well it was
mvl who decided you know if we are going
to win this game we're going to win by
attacking so he went on went forward
with the attack with bishop takes a6 the
all-in worked and remember that at the
amateur level i think it's much easier
to attack and defend and we really saw
this this game hey even at the gm level
i mean it was hard for svidler to find
the correct defense with queen before
with his clock ticking down absolutely
queen b4 for white was a very menacing
threat yes i think that well we
we've said it over and over again blitz
games the aggression and the initiative
usually pays off even if you have to
take a few risks this was a great game
though i mean this was actually almost
hard to watch because it was so tense
for five minute games with so many ups
and downs whereas the first game was
like a little bit just i think it was
like an easy one for wyatt more so it
seemed you thought well more one-sided
this was definitely this one had more
drama oh yeah this one was just so
dramatic for a five minute game this
could easily have been like a 30 minute
game with all those ups and downs that's
true but i like the way randy brought it
home he like played so many precise
moves to win the game exactly clearly um
some natural attacking talent by randy
zingfield there
i think we're getting ready for round
three here
rex starting with the white pieces
it does seem like it's it's all about
white in this tournament in that so far
white has gotten really good positions
um so both of them
trying to play quickly but then
sometimes uh getting a bit too much on
the defensive with black maybe but i
thought black on the first game had a
really big advantage from the opening
and it was a mistake i think by randy at
the end
that uh really allowed rex to well
pretty much queen upon
well let's see if we change the
strategies will you think we'll see
another relopez or do you think rex will
switch it up
i think rex is gonna play e4 but randy's
gonna mix it up and we've got more views
for the start of the game
yes we are back for round three that was
absolutely a fantastic game lots of
drama lots of swings in the end randy
singfield's team won that one randy
you mentioned you were high as a kite
after the game how do you feel coming
into this one
i feel great i'm cool confident feeling
comfortable
much better than last year i think we're
gonna i think we're gonna pull it out
this year
and rex you guys lost that second game
but it's still 1-1 what are your
thoughts now
if he's as high as a kite i told him to
stop using drugs
and there you have it
on to game three
[Laughter]
after that
it's all theory guys so theory
[Music]
okay
the evil eye right now
you don't have to resign here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well no longer down upon the moment you
were but now
this position
is very sharp because we're looking at
chops about what to do next as wesley so
has initiated some great complications
and he sacrificed the piece temporarily
would move queen to d7
now knight c3
and wesley so finally capturing the
night back so even material but black's
pawn structure has been shattered the
question is how does white take
advantage of this position
and upon extra
as kasparov leaves with upon extra super
solid position a definite advantage to
white as fabiano caruana and
vishwanathan anand go into the chair
[Laughter]
optimistic assessments as usual trying
to psych out his opponents this is a
clear mistake he doesn't understand that
the bishop is on b7
it's going to
hit his queen
soon enough
trying to intimidate already with the
trash talking although they know their
worst i think marshall just turned
around in his grave
and the move f5 a hyper aggressive
attacking movement
they would love to shift the pawn off of
c6 but it's there but f5 is an
aggressive move causing fabiano carolina
to pause in this moment although
currently up upon
the attack or the initiative at least
seems to be with black suddenly
the game is changed
[Music]
he said we have the better players says
maxine vashey legrov
according to but we all know at some
point
and the last move by fabian carwana
ikaru nakamura comes into the chair
and
and vasily topolov as
yeah they're well nice very nice
i think i just have a training
right now
you're fine you're doing fine
and white training down all of black's
attacking possibilities
very quickly black is still down upon in
the long term and white with amazing
pieces is rooks double might have a
position here
this is the rookie one berlin
with a bedball structure and an extra
phone something i like next year later
move now
alright look what you do
you fix the dark squares
desperately
quest
he just follows you
okay
what do you do in our french monster
what you do
will he have
enough counter play given that white is
totally dominating the border right now
in space
[Applause]
it looks like anish didn't even want to
get up from the table because the
position is so good and ding lorraine
jumps in and just rips off a second pawn
block is currently down two pawns and
white just looking to trade off the
piece is a huge advantage
huge advantage for white
[Applause]
he
looks like some good team camaraderie as
they're trying to give support to black
in this position given that he is down
two full pawns
and now the move queen to e4
i'm not understanding what he wants to
do
lots of time on the clock for both sides
to get to this position of
semi marshall gamut they call it but
clearly just
not something that black really wanted
to walk into will there be enough
counter players these pieces are close
to the white king
but definitely
not doing enough pressure he has a nasty
plan i don't like that
really
some chinese massage
chinese
and now white is ahead on the clock he
was down quite a bit but he's caused him
to go into a long think and he's
is the touch move
touch move has been called as c6 is now
in the board and now queen to e7
a nasty threat to the rook
on e8
and suddenly it's busted the rook is
under attack cannot be protected
and he has resigned a crushing blow
by daniel
giving white the victim in that game and
rex's team has bounced back immediately
to take a 2-1 lead
rex were you confident
that you would come back in this game i
was confident in my team and you know
what they say you mess with the best you
die like the rest you know what i'm
saying
i do know what you're saying well that's
three rounds in the books these players
now very animated of course rex's team
is up two to one
we'll let you talk about it back in the
studio
from hero to villain randy sinfield i
think he had such a great attack last
game but this time he played five moves
in the opening and it was all over
really this move d5 you might be
thinking we've only played five moves of
chess but d5 i think is enough of a
mistake that any of those guys upstairs
will crush you from this position and
today was no exception after knight
takes c5 there's just too much pressure
on this knight it's almost impossible to
defend it comfortably uh wesley tried
some trick with pawn takes c4 knight
takes e6 queen d7 but black just has no
development after knight c3 pawn takes
rookie one bishop e7 casparo's last move
knight takes e4 gave a dominating
position for white an extra pawn better
pieces better pawn structure and that's
all these guys really needed to crush
the black side
that's right so black having some
problems three wins in a row for white
and uh three strong positions coming out
of the first five moves
we got to see if their teammates are
going to be giving randy and rex some
better advice with the black pieces so
we got two points for team racks and one
point for team randy
yes absolutely crushing performance by
the white pieces so far i think the
openings have really favored white but
not necessarily because of randy or
rex's moves this one definitely was
randy but in the first two i think it
was some grandmasters making mistakes
exactly that was definitely a big part
of it who do you think's the star so far
of the show oh i think it's really
varied up and down but i mean dingley
wren just gave that crushing i think it
was very easy on the first game the star
had to be rex he outplayed randy in that
end game got in the winning pass pawn
but game two it was randy that actually
uh took the stardom role he executed
that attack perfectly in the last game
i'm going to have to say the star was
randy just for the wrong reasons
so from star to villain and we are going
to take a quick break as we look at the
standings here one more time it's 2-1 in
favor of team rex but can team randy
a tight in the race
next round well stay tuned we'll have to
find out
[Music]
[Music]
the grand chess tour
was the brainchild of gary kasparov he
was able to connect a lot of
organizers and players and sponsors to
create what is the best circuit of chess
events that has existed or will exist
and i think we can expect many more
years of great events to come with the
grand chess tour
i remember boris cassidy you know
used to say when people talked about
soviet chess school
he didn't like this term because he said
it was not about the country it was more
about the spirit and he said the best
representative of soviet chess school in
1970 was bob official every time i fly
from new york to san luis i had this
nostalgic feelings and i understood why
because this is where
the spirit of chess is very much alike
your c field cup champion for 2016
grand master wesley center
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
when it comes to preparing for a
tournament like this do you prepare
specifically for every player or is it
just more of a general preparation
i used to be
a guy who would prepare just generally
but i think last
three four years i'm more
preparing against the opponents so the
preparation starts when i find out
who i'm playing and which color
you keep everything very general till
the pairings are done because
nine opponents
two colors you have to cover broad
categories you want to have enough in
your toolkit that you can then pick and
choose very easily so while you say
broad work it's not like you neglect the
details i prefer more in general
i just want myself to feel comfortable
here
and i did not prepare for the party
particular
opponent i mean a lot of it's just been
general preparation on and i mean there
hasn't been a big stopover between uh
bilbao and the sink filled cup i mean
it's only been about a week and a half
since that term ended but still i've
i've been looking at a fair amount on
what my various phones are going to play
and i feel pretty good just as always
i've been doing some chess
i've played a lot in the past few months
so i took a little bit of time to rest
as well i kept in touch with the game
the last week as well i've looked a few
things a little bit well i i would have
liked some more preparation for an event
of this magnitude but on the other hand
i i always welcome you know chances to
play against the world's best i did get
a bit of a warm up playing against mvl
didn't go according to plans so to speak
but
it did give me some much needed practice
you have to have your
plan laid out ahead of time especially
since all the players are pretty
versatile in the opening and can
surprise you and there's a point to
trying to prepare specific things
against against his opponent but i'd say
it's more useful to to have your entire
plan laid out
i'm mike matheny manager of the
cardinals in chess fanatic at the world
renowned chess club and scholastic
center of st louis across from the world
chess hall of fame st louis status as
the chess capital of the nation is on
full display with a welcoming
environment and scholastic outreach
program that works with over 100 schools
our goal is to teach play and promote
the sport so whether you've played for
years or never before we invite you to
experience all chess has to offer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back at the 2016 ultimate
moves which has
been quite exciting so far especially
that a game two battle boy i don't know
if
i can take too many more games like that
my heart almost exploded on that one
well i was upstairs during the break and
i gotta say team randy was huddled up
coming up with opening strategy both
yasser sarwan the legend and wesley saw
himself the winner of the singfield club
giving advice on how to open the game
let's go up to maurice for
round four game four and the players are
intense with a lot of strategies going
on discussions being made about what to
do now
randy you guys took it on the chin the
last game you're down 2-1 what's the
strategy to bounce back
just got to play solid this time and and
uh
i don't know i'm going to stick to the
plan we've got a plan in store we'll see
if we can dance
take it one move at a time
and rex you won the first lost the
second one to third the second time with
the black pieces what's your strategy
for handling the situation now oh it's
easy tatef and katarina told me how to
move the pointy headed guys so i'm ready
i'm ready
all right well it's time for game four
in this epic match up plays have shaken
hands and it's time to go
b3 on move one
[Applause]
all right looking to befuddle rex right
away with the movies not familiar
with and rex
just playing chess developing pieces so
far
clearly this was a strategic insight by
the players
double fiance happening in rex playing
g6
solid play
and the double finger on the board now
we see two being two bishops out
and rex did indeed know how to move the
pointy headed guys
one more move
for randy and knight
with that opening and one more
correction
and uh
wesley soul and gary kasparov
with the black pieces
and because with a solid move
mostly
this is a rich position
not the typical position caspar finds
himself with the black pieces but after
all he was a world champion for many
years for a reason
now playing bishop to g4
that's qws
and kasparov with the sacrifice of a
bishop of course just a sham sacrifice
in this position because the bishop on
b2 would be hanging so pressure on the
knight on e5 and was he so backing up
quickly
backing up to deal with this threat to
his knight and kasparov now playing d4
trying to bury all of white's pieces in
the position and it looks like a
challenge now for white to get anything
into the game his knight on b1 unable to
come out to the c3 square he's dropped
it to a3 instead and anand leaping into
the chairs because prepares to make his
last move
we have a great position
because our pieces are you know they're
developed while black's knight on v8
doesn't have prospects
like squares at some point
our position is additionally very
positional
well he won't get a job as a commentator
anytime soon
and knight to a6 two unusual nights
in the position as they have figured out
a way to develop the wayward knights on
the queen side and now fabiano caron
sitting down playing the move e5
tremendous space advantage for black to
be sure and white trying to figure out
how to play and there goes anan with b4
looking for space himself on the queen
side
karana dropping back with his knights
and a knight to see one
night to see one a retreat by
the five-time world champion approval by
anish giri well you know in this kind of
position you have to either use the
unusual placement of the pieces or just
drop them back and place them usually
so that's what bishop is doing
[Laughter]
i'm just teaching some chess to
grandmasters here
maybe you shouldn't
[Laughter]
and the attack continues and
she now gets up as the knight has gone
to a4 to attack the bishop
gets up and pretends he was never here
responds immediately here comes nakamura
into the chair
all these positions
they slay
themselves usually my night is wrong
it's okay you can do it
don't get there and i capture on before
straight training look they don't allow
me to make mistakes
we're okay
and the clock ticking down four minutes
full four minutes and five seconds for
black white
sorry for white white is a big leader
very pretty sitting pretty on the clock
at least although black is the one with
more space in the position
and now the bishop dropping back
[Music]
[Music]
knowing exactly what to do and it's
proud this crowd is happy
[Applause]
and a sharp move
by
by geary suddenly blowing up the queen
side
[Music]
feeling good about himself and that last
move with all that tension on the queen
side and my team dropping his knight
back making sure no threats to that side
going into a long think now down to two
minutes and 14 seconds and ticking down
anish giri trying to figure out all the
complications of the pawns on the queen
side and he has another creative idea
that he mentioned of playing the move g5
but he decided to go in a different
route just simply capturing on the c4
square and an hour trade
and white seeming like he's holding on
at least for now i think we're going to
win the phone yeah
gary has gone serious as his time has
gone under two minutes quite way ahead
on the clock with three minutes and 28
seconds and maxim seems quite happy
right now
yeah i don't know if i'm happy but i
actually have to pretend
and the gear he's still struggling with
the position
[Applause]
and his rook swinging over
looks like a threat he probably noticed
and yes
f2 guarding against the may threat in
one move
and dingler in the chinese star now
bringing his knight into the game and a
capture
about to happen on c5 with a pawn pawn
takes on c5 the black pawn center now
under tremendous duress unbelievable
as predicted failed the strategies has
failed what is this doing of course he's
explaining me i have played only unleash
i have played things so many times and i
know what he's thinking
what is he thinking he's thinking
how can his teammates get such a
position like this
the position lacks positionality that's
a new one
but he might be right it looks as though
black's position is probably one man and
he has only 56 seconds left and he's
played the move knight to c3
a wild move
and time pressure
up a clear pawn and it looks as though
black species are discombobulated with
no real point here
yeah it's actually an english word
i see the idea now i have now i see the
idea i thought it was that one i like it
i like it too it's a very deep move it's
very deep it's a very deep movement
listen it's it's going to be pretty
successful
down to 51 seconds and he has traded
queens he's going into an end game
despite being down
a pawn and now alone has to get up
with one more move and yasa sirowan with
two minutes 55 black with only 45
seconds left
and rook to c8 has been played and here
comes peter spidler
seven-time russian champion to the table
yasser serwan with two minutes and 50
seconds the time advantage is
overwhelming full two minutes but here
comes yasser bringing his knight around
and
looks as though he's preparing to get
his pawn back instead he's centralized
knight to d4
hyper aggressive move
by
the russian champ
and now black with only 39 seconds but
he seem as though he has come back in
the game used to be a dubious looking
position may still be but white
certainly with a challenge in front of
him despite having the big lead on the
clock yes it looks very challenged
keep the lead on the clock then let's
still thinking trying to solve all the
complexities
[Music]
and now black feeling a lot more
confident about the situation although
that time
disparity will
certainly count at some point in the
game but yasser is still analyzing the
position he's gone into over a minute
think on the clock so far
and his time is quickly evaporating in
terms of the advantage he's not sure
exactly what to do
without playing them beautifully
but e4 was a bit
too risky but that's okay
all right well the clock
is still ticking down now less than a
minute advantage it was a huge edge but
yasser trying to figure out exactly what
to do he's seeing problems everywhere
and not sure what move to make
and now finally he has retreated his
knife
and bishop takes pawn has been played
yesterday
and king to g2 on the board
a couple more moves for their side
and the clock is ticking down 33 seconds
left for black how to proceed
and that's it that's it no more moves
you have to get up and here comes randy
and rex in a highly complex ending
material equality
on the board at the moment
rexing field with only 25 seconds but
randy has slipped under a minute to 53
seconds and counting
[Applause]
19 seconds and ticking down needs to
make a move and he has defended against
the threat the main threat in the
position
[Applause]
knight to b3 trying to befuddle his
opponent
you know what they say if they give you
free chickens you need to take it
and there it goes bishop takes rook on
f2 and wrexham
sacrificing two pieces
one more move for both sides before the
gm's come in there's only 34 seconds
left to 14 seconds
has been played it's up to rex to make
the name
directly he's a movement he's retreating
he's retaining his look and blended
oh
[Applause]
again in the score and tied up
incredible comeback
[Music]
leslie wesley has done it again defeated
the former world champion horse
resignation back to back we are proud
of course gary could not make any moves
because they were going to lose a rook
on the board they're happy that he had
to resign twice without coming back to
the table unfortunately rex's blunder
cost them the game the score is now not
again two to two
we'll be back for more action up here
with some happy grand masters and some
really disconsolate ones as well
wow what a what a game so what do you
make of that position if rook c2 shacked
i i was sure that he was going to play
like you know just a sub move just to
toss it back to the super grand masters
well there was a collective mistake
honestly to leave rex in such a
complicated position with 30 seconds on
the clock that was absolutely terrible
after bishop takes p6 we started getting
this position between randy and rex and
you can see randy making very natural
moves knight d5 comes in hitting the
bishop the bishop must play to c5 in
order to also defend the point on e7 so
there is no check knight takes c3 looks
pretty logical and now of course this
move knight b3 quite dubious we've
learned over and over again two pieces
are worth more than a rook randy decided
okay let's go for the trade put the
knight on d5 and this clearly favors
white but the game is far from over for
example after the move rook c2 check the
king is forced backwards it would be a
very tough complicated end game i think
that it would have been fun to see the
grand masters blitz this one out white
clearly playing for a win but nothing
written in stone no not at all and this
is going to take so long for white to
convert then in fact they probably would
go back to randy interact right and with
the time pressure anything can happen
but instead rook c8 was played and
wesley didn't even sit down when he
slammed the move 97 check
game over and then we're beckoning gary
to come back
we can have an opening strategy session
going on
for randy ready
some kind of french defense for some
reason because
oh
this is for his oh i think this was
during the break it's not now so they
were preparing him for uh
for watching
unless rocks play the french
oh i think they're wondering they're
wondering if rex would roll again
i think they're thinking that this time
after d4
knight f6 knight c3 rex will play d5 and
then they're trying to surprise him with
b4 are they that is i don't think that's
the move over here but okay some opening
strategy there let's see what's going on
in the standings now after four rounds
guess what we are tied up 2-2 team rex
two points team randy two points so the
tension mounts i absolutely it seems
like over and over it's wide winning
that's right and
we've been going back and forth with the
time situation
um but i think that both teams should
really try to avoid the 30 giving um
randy or max less than a minute i mean
they could barely sit down and also we
need to uh get a note to yasser i think
so he thinks it's correspondence chess
but it's actually blitz right yeah i
think he was worried that like he needed
to find the the precise move there they
were gonna completely go down
he answered with a two minute time
advantage and when he left he had like a
20 second time advantage and even even
smither on his part i think he should
have played he should have tried to play
even faster to give rex like a full 40
seconds no i agree there's a big
difference between 20 seconds and 40
seconds right as i said earlier i think
a lot of pressure is on yasser and peter
because they are the ones handing the
game to the amateurs they have to put
them in a good position comfortable in
the clock with easy moves to find on the
board yeah i think they might have
wanted
they should have really put a lot of
thought into that decision i think
somebody who's really uh thinking a lot
about tandem chess i might have put
lavon on this on this penultimate player
i think i think levon would have been a
wiser choice because we've seen that you
know peter's making a lot of proper
moves but he's complicating the game a
little bit too much well lavon would
have been for randy right but yeah for
rex's team
maybe fabi but let's go back up to
maurice
two to two tense moments here as they
have been talking opening strategy and
of course rex not feeling great about
how he handled that last game rex how
are you going to make a comeback right
now
the most dangerous animal in the world
is a wounded animal
there i've said it man and uh randy
you've heard your dad trash talk all
your life what are your thoughts about
this game
you know i'm just going to listen to my
team
they're giving me good solid advice
making me comfortable they're cheating
all right well here we go
the fifth game the penultimate round
critical as rex once again gets white so
far i believe white has won every single
game in the competition will the trend
continue well we'll see as the game's
about to start
[Music]
an exchange french on the board now
with c4
banged down by rex infield with
authority
one more move by randy and gary kasparov
now sitting down bishop to e6 on the
board
next year
looking for a signature an interesting
idea after this last move
pressuring the c-pawn
[Laughter]
surprisingly this movie should be six is
not as bad as possible
people will take on d5
[Music]
a relaxed wesley soul the winner of the
singfield cup this year and he looks
like he's truly enjoying himself
sparrow has now played queen c2
defending the knight on c3
and knight to c6 quickly by wesley
and chasing the bishop from the v4
square to a better place
backing up
quite calmly was wesley in that
situation
you know if not every day i get better
and that's it five moves in
and it is now fabiano caruana's turn and
he has castle vishyanan
coming to the table as well
he dreams about it
[Music]
we will learn
[Music]
and a steep time edge surprisingly just
out of the opening a full minute edge
plus already on the clock for black
moves the blockade on d5 that night a
monster
what is the compensation that white will
reveal
as he has space for sure but looks like
black has no weaknesses in this
structure
bishop dropping back from that a5 square
now pointing in the direction of the
white king
nakamura now coming to the table
and ana needing to make his next move
if he knows who's coming next
oh
e8 has been played and now it is
nakamura's turn
nakamura playing the best game of the
tournament in a sing-field cup
and it is his turn to show what kind of
attacking style he has or
how he can continue this position to put
pressure on the black forces
and the khan bishop to d2
knight they told me to play
he's uh telegraphing his capture on d4
is the paulo pointing at the pawn
big edge on the clock 4 25 and now the
knight dropping back to f3
and back to e5 is tonight
both sides having great centralization
but black with a superior structure and
white oh
in this position but it is his last move
so he will not be able to continue and
he has done it he has played a super
aggressive move
and now we have a wild position
where aneesh giris doesn't seem thrilled
at all that his pawn is sitting on the
f4 square and he has to play
aggressively somewhat but he's played
the move bishop to e3 guarding his pawn
on d4 he's blowing up the aggressiveness
here
i'm sorry
i'm not going to give you any respect
yes
now the knight is returned
to
aggressively attacking that d4 pawn
trying to knock the legs from under
the pawn and he's not happy with the
pawn on f4
now with 157 they have a full
three-minute lead this is unusual
but not quite three minutes not quite
three minutes two minutes and 10 seconds
it looks like
but it's still a gigantic edge on the
clock as white is forced to play defense
to defend his weaknesses it's an
illusion it's not a defense it's
recruitment no but the reason i'm
waiting because every time they make a
move and advance some porn it's a
weakness
this is what chess is about this is
exactly what chess is about
this is the bulgarian school of chess
and now
trying to take the legs out from under
the isolated pawn but suddenly knight to
c4
attacking the pawn attacking the queen
on d6 and the strong bishop on v6 anish
geary known as a sterling defender
and he's now grabbed the two bishop's
advantage
that's it that's it and now dingler in
his turn with the white pieces he's been
given a disadvantage on the clock and
he's got to get his head right in this
position to see what to do next
a big time advantage though two minutes
now i have five chasing the bishop
backwards
weakness
and criticizing his partner's moves but
down to 126 is ding lorraine and needing
to find a continuation that can have
some flow in the position
it's your partner though yeah but i mean
i'm objective here
and no matter the partner when the move
is awful i say it's awful
you're not
great teammate
and now doing lorena down to 1
19
but and with a two-minute disadvantage
and the first trade of rooks and now
queen to
g
[Music]
this is
team randy doing well in this position
as team
rex is the first time white seems to be
uh in some serious trouble right now
and that was the fifth move and here
comes
peter svidler as aronian has to make his
last move in the position
hey you see this is a lesson on
overextended phones
this is a lesson we all have to learn
from it
you know i think if we meet this game we
should get two points because we win ah
it's so simple what i was thinking about
of course of course lord
show them
teach them right now yasuo yasasirwan to
follow up on the idea by lavon aronian
and svidler has to make a move and he
played queen takes on c3
and yasser scoping the board
as black has a wonderful looking
position
can he finish it off
two and a half minutes left on the clock
for black a big edge will black finally
win a game in this competition
yes smiling for the moment
and ripping off his pawn a nice tactical
shot
he played nice now black is ahead by a
pawn in the
position and yet another move
consolidating and black is ahead by a
pawn very difficult now for white to
figure out all the complications and
bishop back to f1 counting on his two
bishops possibly to maintain some kind
of defensive posture but now suddenly
and rook takes and we see a trade
of queens from the board was that it and
now it is rex
it is rex and randy
in a wild position right now
it is rex's turn
to make a move
and rex has retreated his knight
he's rook excuse me he's up a pawn
thanks rex for the correction 26 seconds
left on the clock for white
and it is
black to move with over two minutes the
time advantage is huge right back to e4
[Applause]
and rex has played the move bishop to d3
and rex says
[Applause]
[Music]
and team randy with a big win with the
black pieces
black has finally won a game
tough situation for rex haters gonna
hate
well they're feeling quite good about
themselves as team randy as they finally
won with the black pieces uh tough
situation for rex as he's hung a rook in
two straight games he's gonna have to
get himself together and make a comeback
we'll see if he can do so for the last
game
i mean they just keep giving him no time
to play his game i think rex he shows up
to the board he sees he has 30 seconds
left tries to make a move ends up
blundering a rook and cost him another
game yeah and the funny thing was before
right before uh yasser um got a really
good position for black but then um in
this position we could have taken on b6
instead of playing um
would have well it would have been about
even game but i really like this tactic
by yasser knight takes c3 aronian saw it
he set it up you said okay it's simple
and of course this brilliant bishop
takes f3 the point being that after
bishop takes f5 sorry fishing takes a
five rook d1 check just casts wide the
game as there's no way to defend the
king properly and
bishop f5 just i think was the move of
the game indeed and to credit this
fiddler that he he played some pretty
good moves quickly here in order to um
try to get the situation a bit better
for rex no he definitely was a pretty
bad it was pretty bad spot he definitely
outplayed yasser i think this move
bishop f1 was a great b6 i thought was
really slow and after rook g3 he started
creating some complications that allowed
him eventually to have this possibility
of rook takes p6 that being said they
played so slow
but the i think the earlier players put
peter in a tough situation in that one
yeah ding loren played way too slowly
thingy round what about gary gary yeah
yeah
like 45 seconds for five moves you can't
do that in blitz yeah especially with
this situation they need to give um i
think they need to conceive of it that
you need to give racks 30 especially
when they're playing white because they
sit there first yes you need to give
them 30 seconds to sink into the
position not 30 seconds total 30 seconds
before they make the first of the five
moves absolutely the players here with a
little bit of snack and strategy and a
little bit of time
by the way
let's tune in
to do it
early on f4 which hikaru did
i mean the thing is like it's normally
okay in blitz to do something like f4
but against this type of grand masters
f4 such a committal move it's so
weakening and i think that
every player that sat down with the
white pieces would have loved to grab
this spot and put it back on f2
that's right indeed um i think uh black
uh the from the opening they just got a
game
like and uh black i'll play them well
let's be honest that was brilliant
opening strategy by the players we saw
them look specifically at this variation
with the exchange french what's going on
jen is there some kind of leak how do
they know rex's repertoire well randy
and rex do play
well i guess that is true
and rex uh rex likes that opening and he
makes it very clear so
i think that uh after bishop e6 though
um you didn't like the way gary played
the opening no i think he's uh i think
he's a little rusty the move bishop b6
is quite bad but the point is that you
go knight ge2 that's what i remember you
play knight g2 with the knight f4 and
suddenly the bishop is really really
awkward on e6 uh it's funny because gary
used to play the exchange franchise
white in the early 90s and i guess the
early 90s is just too far away from now
because knight ge2 is considered to be
the refutation of bishop e6 right just
taking and playing knight f3 does give
black a rather comfortable position not
that it's bad for white by any means but
but i think black was just very happy
and in a blitz game playing against the
isolated poem when white has really no
initiative is really comfortable and you
can see that white struggles to find
moves and that's why he played so slowly
exactly so after five randy ahead by
three points so in order for team rex to
even it up
again absolutely last game coming up is
huge for team rex they absolutely need
to win and we go up to maurice ashley
for game six
well black has finally won a game and
this is a critical game of course for
team rex they are down three to two rex
has made errors in the last two games
but now it's time for the bounce back
let's get to the players
randy you've got to be feeling good your
team has given you incredible support
they have been wesley and yasser are two
of the best coaches in the world i swear
to god they made me comfortable they
give me great advice let's see what dad
does with this one all right rex you've
got to win this one to continue the
battle what are your thoughts clearing
your head from the last two games
i don't want to face jennifer shahadi
losing with the black pieces therefore
we're going to win with the black pieces
it's really simple bowl prediction by
rex well we'll see what happens now if
there's a victory by wreck side and
there's a tie
we don't do ties here in the club we
will have a playoff game to break the
tie but at the moment we'll see what is
decided game six with all to play for
about to begin
this is like the nba finals but we have
a super home court advantage right yeah
and there you go and the game has begun
knight to f3 another solid move and c5
played
looking for some aggression and now to
fianchetto as well
[Applause]
[Applause]
jumps in with gary kasparov who played
d4 and this is the position gary has
played many times in his career he's
very comfortable here
position two days ago
no equality
wesley's trash talking is intense right
now and the black queen penetrating into
the position with threats
of c5
that was
and now b6 by gary as
anand sits down and fabiano caruana into
the chair
[Applause]
[Music]
bishop f4
ostensibly a pawn sacrifice which has
now been accepted in a3
chasing the queen back
and the deep concept of how to win that
pawn back by anan and now the c5 pawn's
about to go
[Music]
[Music]
a claim of repetition was possible
according to lavon but vishy avoiding it
playing for advantage and now d6
one last move
that was five and on now up from the
board
fine performance
in the tournament in the sink field cup
nakamura coming back at the end
with a great win
a tense opening position right now
knight to b4
that was under attack
time is going to be a factor again
not really because
they're both over four minutes this time
no much
time spent and now a knight
sinking itself on the d5 square
white looking like he has an optical
edge for sure in this position at least
and the knight takes and knight takes
yet again
no
no no no no no no
one more move from both sides one more
bone crushing movement remember
every single win by white secures the
entire
tournament he's just played bishop to f3
so much better
now
in the chair it's his turn to figure out
what to do can he secure the victory
for his team a trade of
light square bishops
black with
a small edge now on the clock as white
is stopping to think about the position
looks like a grandmaster game going on
right now very solid chest
and they are looking to see is there any
opportunity for advantage can white
stabilize everything and pull off the
win a draw is all they need in fact yeah
and white will win themselves
don't worry
we need to fight you say uh
come on
of course
you're an active guy
we need to put maximum confidence
let's go maxim
and now knight d5 trading off a pair of
rooks is white
after this would be one move and now
queen to c
four this is looking like a serious
chess game lots of time on the clock in
an interesting position
and it's not you and it's not me
that's mine
knight back to f4 as aneesh
claims that someone is getting it
outplayed and lavonne
sits down as anish gets ready to make
his last move and it's rook to b8
applying pressure to the b-pawn and ding
lorraine
i believe still raided the number one
blitz player in the world sitting down
and lavonne aronian
rating does not mean anything
in blackwood some activity for sure in
this position and now bishop takes a
trade in b4 and e5 and ding playing
quickly
i know it was too aggressive for you
knight b5
i'm sorry yesterday but today you can
trash talk me i'm playing like a god
if i might say so much myself
as they say you don't praise yourself
nobody will break you
in your case this is correct
[Applause]
game it's a muslim situation black
keeping the edge on the clock as well
he's got a
monster bishop on d4
looking for some potential in the game
and now white's clock is ticking down
only two and a half minutes left on the
clock will white be able to stain this
pressure by blocking out e3
chasing the bishop out of the d4 square
and it's yasa's turn to sit down
bishop to b6 and peter svidler joins the
fray as well as yasser stops to think
about how to handle black's initiative
as it grows
and a trade and now a4
looking to take advantage of the 2-1 on
the queen side now rook to d2
the knight lacking security and now
under attack needing to find a good
square but there are no forward squares
forthcoming
spike squares are fine
backwards squares are for coming i think
and
you can't go in one direction
and now a minute deficit on the clock
for white is hungry for a move and he's
playing yeah
where where are you going
it's a secret it's too difficult
this is a very good thing
a5 yeah
a5
and the question is what will happen now
we've seen some strange things happen in
this pairing we'll see what happens now
as it is
randy's turn to move
[Applause]
okay don't
pressurize all right here we go
141 lots of time on the clock for rex
bishop to b4 guarding
critically guarding the d6 pawn keeping
the pressure in the position and is now
up to randy can he come up with any kind
of counter play in this position he's
played rook to d5
this is good it's a good move
this is a great move and rex now
collecting upon
black is ahead by a pawn in this
position technically is it enough to win
it's not clear oh yeah now
[Applause]
it's nothing
it's a b5 nothing's going he lost three
moves rex to make three more moves with
ample time on the clock and he
solidified his bishop
on the c5 square
any move is good
123 to white
we've only seen one game get past
the time control only one get that is
get past this pairing
only once will we get to see the other
players come back in as four games have
ended in this pairing
hungry to sit back down and continue the
game
one more move for randy one more move
for rex and we'll see the gm's
two more for x my apologies
and he's made his move now down to one
that's a check
and he's moved out and now it is
rex's turn once more
no suggestions
no suggestions rex now at one
three lots of time still one more time
life is good
it's a beautiful place beautiful
and rex
thinking carefully now 1 30 his clock is
ticking
and he has gone to the seventh rank and
now it is gary caspar finally able to
sit back down in the chair versus wesley
so feeling very good about himself
[Applause]
as this one will win more material after
knight to c4 and sparrow feeling great
as wesley so not happy at all
all right they're realizing they're
going to lose
what looks like lots of material in the
position it's going to be not just one
but maybe three pawns after this last
move by wesley wesley looking
desperately for a way to continue but
this one does not look good i don't see
any chances as they're about to lose not
just
not a pawn he's not they're gonna lose
two more pawns it looks like and he's
going to be down three pawns with just
about no chances this move
is part of sniffing it out
and now he's defending the position
sewing some bravado with
1
16 extra time in the clock so wesley has
found a way to save the second pawn but
it is not looking pretty right now save
the third pawn that is down two
and that's it and gary is just turning
to make the final
but he's only down to 55 seconds it's
not a lot of time in the clock black is
absolutely winning there's no question
about that and he's just captured on g4
with check with a smile satisfied smug
as
now
it is fabiano caruana's turn can he
close the door aaron white
and tie the game tie the match and force
a tie break he has just 40 seconds left
on the clock and he's playing the move
rook to d2
fishing
[Laughter]
and now bishop takes and now three pawns
down suddenly is white no i will look
good
clearly a completely winning position
for black and now h5 check
and king g3 and this looks just over
and tapadav saying he's not resigning 25
seconds left nakamura understands these
type of positions
and now how to win looks pretty academic
this position is going to be some kind
of chicanery is going to have to happen
five news played and now checking out
mvl with white they are forcing each
other
and now he's giving away this pawn on g6
and now not down
as much as before but look
five is through eight five has been
played and now it is yasser
and peter svidler there's only one
chance one remote chance it seems
for white is if
they can get it back to rex and randy
and hopefully the amateurs don't
finish the job right but it's 11 seconds
left
[Music]
and that's it
[Music]
no talking
rex has 18 seconds on his clock to two
seconds
two seconds on the clock for randy and
now e2 on the board a check has been
played king over
another check has been played harassing
the king
and yet another check playing quickly
that's it
and now 8-6 on the board
one second left for white
he cannot allow his clock to fall
unfortunately
[Music]
who's next what's next
and now
and
now with a three second and that is it
the time has run out
[Applause]
and the game is over
what a comeback for rex's team the score
is tied we're going to work out the tie
breaks they have they're now tied up
knotted out black won two in a row after
not winning any of the first four games
they're knotted up we'll see what the
tie break is like i think they have
something funky planned we'll be back in
a couple of minutes
i really think that game showed you
might need a little bit more than three
second delay because it seems like
physically the players are having
trouble um swapping out for that last
part you gotta be faster yeah but it was
actually we sent a lot of blunders in
the rex randy pairing but it was
actually wesley saw that had the final
blunder of this game he sat down on the
board and in this position he decided to
blitz out knight c4 they didn't sit down
he just played 794 huge mistake as gary
kasparov put down the rook on c2 and
suddenly wesley realized that this rook
is attacking the knight if the knight
moves the bishop takes this pawn which
is not guarded by this pawn because of
this rook pinning against the king and
there is just no good move here he's
down too much material made it so easy
for team rex had he played the move
knight f1 perhaps he could have survived
later into the end game of course still
a very good position for black up a pawn
but hey this could have gone either way
absolutely and uh yeah randy and rex
actually both played the end game okay
randy was trying to relocate the knight
and save himself friend and rex put the
work on a2 i think i think they did
really well absolutely the uh position
before this as uh john is explaining
they actually played this part of the
game quite well positioning the rook on
d5 trying to activate the knight trying
to activate the rook the knight came
here i thought it was a good move knight
g5 was also possible making g2 but it
was it's not usual that the mistake here
came from the winner of the singfield
cup
well will they come back we are gonna
have some kind of tie break so we'll get
the details on what that is in just a
second
and we actually have tony rich to
explain it to us in just a little bit
but let's take a look at the score
as we go into the tie break of ultimate
moves the father-son showdown ends in
the most exciting way
we didn't have it in the sync field cup
but we got in an ultimate move three on
three what a match it's been so far
going back and forth no team has had
more than a point lead at any point it's
just incredible chats here
that's right and uh i think that
there were just like some really great
games in this match so far the one that
really stands out to me though is that
second game where maxine played bishop
takes a6 like oh yeah
that was amazing this game was pretty
good too i mean if you look at some of
the moves that uh that black played um
to kind of increase his advantage i like
the way ding lauren played he played
very quickly um and he really utilized
the fact that black was just better in
that position white didn't have a lot of
counter play black had that nice bishop
one g7 and the c file there is a reason
thing loren is the number one blitz
player in the world even ahead of magnus
carlsen i mean the guy's just a monster
when it comes to blitz and he's just
showing it he plays really really good
moves and i think he's starting to
understand a little bit more of this tag
team chas i don't think he really got in
the first couple games and he played a
little bit too slowly but this game he
played quickly and well
and we've got
tony and maurice to explain how this
tiebreak is going to work
now i'm hearing a format that i've never
seen before in any professional
competition maybe not even amateur
competitions
please tony rich explain to us what you
guys have devised so the tie break for
all them all the marbles will be one
game where the players will alternate
every single move you only make one move
at a time now since it's so much
commotion we've increased the time limit
it'll be 10 minutes with a three second
delay
each player will make their one move and
then rely on their teammates to follow
up
incredible format it's going to be a
gangsters lineup but we'll see how it
transpires here as we're about to begin
the tie-break game in just a few minutes
might as well move the chairs out of the
way why even have them there only one
move per player that is just some
mind-boggling chess imagine so many
ideas coming
trying to get them to come together
actually i actually think you're right
though hollander i think they should do
this outstanding i think it would make
more sense but of course you'd have to
get a different type of table
but i do think that would make more
sense and here i think that you're right
i would probably pick lavonne as the uh
the the star the setup guy
for for um no for randy i'm sorry for
randy rex i don't know who i would pick
either probably either fabio hikaru i
just think they get him more you know
they've spent a lot of time here they
live in st louis i think they would and
they also have a lot of experience with
american chess i i think they might be
the best picks what do you think well i
think they're not gonna have a choice we
are almost on the game and i think well
rex and randy they only get to play one
move not five so i mean as long as they
play an okay move they'll just keep the
game going they have to not blunder
that's going to be the key well that's
why the setup is so important um for
both uh peter and yasser who set them up
to try to see if they can make a move
that might make randy or x make a
blunder or at least take a lot of time
and influence the rest of the game and
the players now have a lot more time to
think but it's going to be weird because
only one move to make what do you really
think about
i think uh yeah it's going to be well
yes you're going to feel guilty if
you're the one who spends like a whole
minute yeah that is like i think that's
one of the issues and that's why you've
seen mistakes even from players like
hikaru
um you mentioned not seeing that tactic
that he would normally see in a blitz
game and we also saw that mistake by
wesley nobody wants to be the one to
leave randy or rex in the lurch with
hardly any time but that's what also
creates more blunders nobody wants to be
the villain here as it's for all the
marvels
time for a game coming up
that's right i can't wait to uh to see
this one this one's really going to be a
crowd pleaser and i guess well i guess
there aren't very many draws in this
format that's the point i cannot imagine
that a game like this ends in a trouble
but you never know this was the most
likely one right i mean
um it was it was it could have it could
have been another draw in certain
circumstances at least there are a lot
of trades and you can imagine that
somehow something goes wrong and there
were further trades but it is very
unlikely in this format
yeah
see as the players are setting up see
what's going on seems like they're
almost ready there
i think i see everybody standing up
though i don't really think there's
chairs
yeah maybe they are maybe they are
getting rid of the option of sharers i
think they might have taken your advice
alejandra
and we've got maurice with the start of
the game so he'll explain
and we are in the critical tie-break
game it is tied at 3-3 right now this is
for all the marbles if the game is a
draw we're gonna run it back we don't
play that in these parts no ties it is
now a lot of pressure on these players
it's never gone this far rex how are you
feeling your team came back to tie it up
what do you think of your chances in the
last game
almost 100 percent
why would you think that because look at
my team how are you going to beat these
guys look at their team how can they win
randy as usual your dad is modest
what are your chances in this one
it sounds like he's ready to shoot
himself in the foot with that
overconfidence here let's see what
happens all right let's in dc what
happens the players are shaking hands
and the game has begun remember one move
at a time
as the players
come in and out i've never seen just
physical activity and it's just that
somehow it's in berlin anyway
it's phil and berlin
and d3 avoiding the typical end game as
they have traded
and aronian coming in playing bishop d6
this was seen actually in the singfield
cup uh during one of the rounds and i
think it was peter's fiddler actually
who had white against
against
anan in the tournament
and now castles by randy and castles by
rex and now it's kasparov's turn to come
up with a move and d4 still looking very
much like the game that was played
between svidler and anand and here comes
anand as queen takes d4 changing the
character of the position bishop to c5
now attacking the queen
it is nakamura's turn the players also
have to strategize they have to watch
the game and stay in line as well
so far playing quickly the first bit of
hesitation by nakamura as he looks to
find a place for his queen and he's
dropped back to d3
and now rook to e8 was played bishop to
g5 attacking the queen f6 chasing the
bishop away here comes ding loren
is bishop dropping back to f4 it's
erroneous turn to come in and here comes
peters fiddler as aronian considers the
position hard to play when you only get
one move and the other player cannot
continue and follow up with your ideas
one shot one opportunity and he's
stopping and he's saying the arms are
sweaty well they got a lot of time on
the clock there's plenty of time to play
this game remember it's a 10
minute game
on the surface it looks kind of already
yeah
[Music]
and now queen e7 and i think the players
now have slowed down and realized how
much time they do have on the clock and
this has been one of the more classical
games so far
really interesting position as peters
fiddler
stops to look at this position he is
looking quite comfortable
this format is unusual
naka what do you think about this format
it's pretty crazy have you ever done
something like this before i know but i
think we're doing very well and i think
we're gonna win so
i'm feeling pretty good normally
confident nakamura saying white is doing
really well this position is indeed
a deep one
lots of possibilities in this case black
still yet to develop his queen side
while white has some space
and svidler going into a deep thing is
the first deep thinking
right now in the game
and he has taken this pawn on c7 is
captured upon boldly
taking this pawn and
yasser staring at the board now trying
to figure out what to do and he has
taken the pawn on e4 now it is rex's
turn
and then his rex is turning to move
discover
right here
and now
rex
trades queens
trades queens in the position
now a very
solid position for black taking on c7
and this is not what
white wanted out of the position and
kasparov now penetrating to the d6
square this game looks like it's
sort of equalized
more or less everything looks very solid
here no we're better do you want them no
no no no
and now bishop takes d6 there's a guy in
game these guys would draw in their
sleep no question about that
but it seems like you maxim feels like
this is a tricky end game yeah i mean
you need to realize that not because
there's opposite colored bishops it's
equal points but black is more active
simply
everywhere
is going to be dominated by two pawns
at some point and then he's going to
suffer
and we're going to regret all what he
said because he's going to look stupid i
had a dream
all right well we'll see this position
does not look like much
but
they are going to continue to play it
and nakamura trying to figure out how to
maybe realize some
advantage out of the position
black is confident that they've
equalized the position i would agree as
well this does not look like much
happening here for white no we're better
now we're clearly
[Music]
fury didn't seem happy with the last
move and now
now
criticizing his opponents yet again
partners partners
his partners
[Applause]
[Applause]
very sharp continuation looks
threatening
for white however there are some
tactical possibilities that he has
analyzed
and both sides seem to be confident in
their position for being better it seems
unlikely that that is the case
and again lots of time now the night
dropping back
to the b3 square
svidler coming in and then it will be
rex's turn to play so far adjust the
position at night to see
we're going to cut your knight with the
phone
the concept in this type of position is
that the knight on e4 would dominate our
knight on b3 but tonight
yes perfect
easy
exactly
trying to throw off his opponent as
usual is
erroneous everything's so personal
[Music]
lots of time on the clock for wrexham
field to try to figure out this position
see all the threats
and make a move this game
certainly an intriguing one this is for
all the marvels are now f3
attacking the bishop on
g4
garrick is far off the followers
randy singh phil now
thinking about his move
going deep into
a calculation right now
and bishop back to c3
indirectly defending the pawn on c2
the tactical idea here is looks like
that position that move looks like it
holds up white's position in defense
and
wesley is clear on that it looks like
that white feels that they're safe right
now gary looks like you made a nice move
there i put bishop on the position where
he's defended you know so
solid
by the way what he's thinking is it's a
good move
and now 1983 rook f2
[Applause]
and now
it looks like
potentially
and white is down upon for the moment
white
currently down upon
but can he maintain the balance
knight to d4 forcing rook takes f2 king
takes f2
and now knight to c2 and now show
technique yeah
so black seems as though he has secured
a pawn advantage
black is up certainly ahead but can he
win with the presence of the opposite
colored bishops on the board as the
knights have traded off
and svidler comes and brings his rook to
the e-file white
with a disadvantage but it's going to
take some technique on black's part to
prove anything at all as rex
comes to the table as does randy again
four minutes and 30 seconds for white
seven minutes
for black
um
initiating a very active threat in the
position and it looks like white is
thrilled by this defensive plan
which in fact is a very aggressive plan
looks like attack is the best defense
and king to g6 avoiding that check it is
now kasparov's turn and the rook is now
down on the seventh rank b6
defending the pawn on b7 and now is
fabiano caruana but g4
controlling the black king somewhat
nakamura coming in as anan considers the
position
a5
and the bishop back to c3 and this is
still looking quite drawish to my eyes
but black has
black has an extra pawn but white has
plenty of compensation by way of his
active
white is better pieces speaking in this
position
because i'm going to start attacking the
kings very soon
[Laughter]
that was one of the more interesting
comments all day
and now f4 a big move with the pawns
and
black is clear that this is not an easy
position
at all
to play with white getting all this
initiative and h3 on the board
and svidler coming on
aronian trying to figure this out
clearly black
is not happy with how this has
transpired or they have to figure out
exactly what to do as the trades have
happened and now
it is yasha surawar with six minutes
left
brexit field to move next
no suggestions or grunts
involuntary noises not allowed
remember
and now rook to d8
is on the board
and rexing field now back in the saddle
3 minutes and 46 seconds left
and he's played f5 check
and this looks very active
very active
for
white
and he has backed out of check
but this hangs the f pawn and suddenly
black is in trouble despite the presence
of the opposite colored bishop and this
move very difficult to handle rook g7
check that king move is now compromised
black tremendously
and only move to not just die
immediately
and king to g3
white now on top for sure but
can he conclude this game as
anand now attacks the pawn
on a2 make
[Music]
nakamura knowing they have a real edge
here naka trying to find the knockout
below
and bishop back
to c3 quiet
retreat but with a lot of poison five
minutes on the clock vasily topple off
takes the pawn and now
black is again up a pawn black is ahead
by a pawn
and hesitating as geary before playing
g5
with some force two-minute edge almost
on the clock for black sting lauren
comes in maxim vashilograph thinking
about the move
critical game the winner
wins the match
and
tremendous pressure
on the black king side nothing to move
totally tied down and how to make any
progress extraordinarily difficult for
black as his pieces just don't seem to
have any possibilities here
[Music]
it's getting caged horribly
on that square where to go
and he has retreated
and peter spidler look at these chops
as
yasser sarwan comes in shaking his head
can't be happy with the situation now
it is
white's
game to win and f6
has been played
and it looks like they're not happy and
gary kasparov animated not happy with
that last move
as it's going to be rex singfield's move
next why are they complaining it's hard
to imagine as sparrows
not happy with what the last move
with the last move that transpired on
the board angry at his his teammate
there now rook to d8
it is now rex's turn in a tense position
a big edge no question for white
will he find
a great continuation here
challenging moment time
not a factor right now
a devastating shot keeping all the
advantages in the position is now team
rex with two pass pawns a king
in deep trouble and a happy gary casparo
is clearly
white
this looks over it's hard to stop the
mating threats that are coming on the
board the black king
[Applause]
congratulations to team rex
[Applause]
randy
has
over performed by a mile yes played
really well
there you go
rex your last game proved to be your
best of all how's it feel to win the
rubber match against your son i feel
like the blind squirrel who found a
walnut
[Laughter]
well the win goes to dad today
rexingfield the champion of ultimate
moves certainly was an entertaining
match we hope you enjoyed it back to you
in the studio
well that game
seemed like it might be a little bit
dull but then it kind of blew up well
just one wrong move in an opposite color
bishop end game is all it takes for it
to
look very very dangerous randy with this
move king h7 just got himself into so
much trouble because after the chuck
that was given by rex he had pretty much
the choice of any move king g5 i think
is kind of okay but it looks really
dangerous to go forward simply king h6
was probably the easiest the idea is
that bishop d2 check first of all is not
really possible because of the rook but
even
uh if it was it's really not that
dangerous instead the move king h7 right
because then your kin goes back to a7
and we're no longer threatening bishop
c3 that's right bishop f6 and after
bishop f6 even for grand masters this
position is impossible to play black's
king is just getting mated over and over
again again in the variations the rook
had to go to jade but you can see how
passive black
is at the end of the day what the
difference was rex outplayed randy in
the final game that's right bishop b4
was a good move putting some pressure on
and let's take a look at the final score
4-3 um
really a fun form at all and a close
match what a close match even the last
game black was ahead for most of it had
an extra problem was pushing and it came
down to the wire that's right and milan
said that his team over performed and i
know what he means because a lot of the
superstar blitz players were actually on
rex's team but i think the team spirit
was really admirable and i think that
actually both randy and rex played great
shots today i think they've come a long
way from blundering queens and making
illegal moves to actually executing
excellent attacks playing really good
moves overall i think they played the
best chess i've seen them play
yeah well it keeps getting better here
at the sink field cup and it ultimate
moves but we are part of something even
bigger the grand chess tour and that
gets started again in december
absolutely we go to london for the
london chess classic starting december
8th that's going to be an exciting event
wesley saw going into london with a huge
bonus what is it a 10 point lead a
commanding lead only not morrigan
stopping only nakamura can
mathematically stopping and that's by
winning the tournament if nakamura
doesn't win the tournament wesley still
pretty much guarantees himself the grand
chest to her victory well thank you all
for watching us these last two weeks
especially today it really was a ball
signing off for the whole team here with
spectrum studios in the st louis chess
club i'm jennifer
thanks for watching
so
[Music]
you